dela é uma peixaria no terek bom
esta foi também perguntado muito os meus
amigos como eu disse que abriria uma
peixaria assim o câncer que não fosse a
parceria né
então quando uma parceria e talvez seja
uma galeria uma coisa assim
quanto ao design e talvez o assunto ia
com exposições um restaurante que era um
restaurante que agora muitos
restaurantes há cinco anos lá quando
você não sabe muito bem o que vai
acontecer lá dentro das duas provas
também poder ser um restaurante mas eu
tive que explicar que nós nós queremos
trazer para cá um conceito novo que é
uma coisa que é uma peixaria governo
depois fresco que os bichos então isso é
bom é quando convidaram para vir falar
cá eu aceitar aí fiquei muito orgulhosa
por chamarem os aveirenses
só quem anda enviado às regras
assim sem saber quais serão as regras
uma das regras é não vender em palco
eu não sei se isso vai acontecer nos
próximos 27 minutos perto de um popular
do país
weah fred está presente quilombos aqui
portanto vamos imaginar que esse negócio
nunca vai acontecer cá e não voltar a
vender é bom então lançamos nosso os
três sócios o meu nome é joão mateus
sofrer em seu país onde vivia até os 18
anos
o design da mãe quando voltou a viver
polysora fui trabalhar em publicidade
pode descobrir que sabia fazer o mec
criou situação mas o que sou e design é
isso que eu faço não vi a linha
o ruim é que tá cada um é um não vão
sentir o cheiro
o rei também é designer tem uma paixão
grande por marcas e e sabe fazer uma
coisa muito bom em que juntar pessoas e
foi ao conjunto a mim e ao filipe o
filipe é e artista plástico e tem esta
vaga stover
embora seja um boneco o filipino hoje
produzir tem uma coisa que nos deixa
muito orgulhosos bom nada explica porque
é que nós conseguimos fazer uma parceria
há uma razão para isso é nós os três
juntos temos um histórico familiar que é
centenário do coxa
as nossas famílias a minha mãe é baixar
o edital e vendo os pais na folha que é
o networking é mais com ela do que
comigo tanto vende para a china foi a
minha vó eu vou ver nenhum país a mãe
foi vendo uma parte da família que eu
peguei o rasto a minha mãe desde
pequenina é transmitiu sempre foi muito
claro pra mim pro meu irmão que que a
minha mãe não crio nossa trabalhar com
poste e foi por isso que foi uma
licenciatura desculpa
vou tentar dar um jeito ruim ruim mais
do que eu ainda tenho uma imagem da
família envolvida com esta coisa do
negócio pode portanto tem pai mãe e foi
bom e em várias avós
antes disso eu fui aos 6 anos também
tomou uma decisão muito importante que
ter uma certa altura da vida dela foi
fechada há seis anos tinha certeza
absoluta e eu decidi que não queria ser
o cheiro nunca passava muitas noites né
com os partilhavam um carrinho e eu
correspondi piloto e portavam carinho
daquela vida possível cap cana dura no
cristo a vida dela
só dou 30 anos mas a mesma
o filipe é é ainda mãe partilha connosco
e história familiar de pessoas da minha
vendeu paz e bem vindo a perceber sendo
na área então esta parceria fica em uma
praça a praça das flores fica entre o
preço real é a cinderela na assembleia
da república
caçá a parceria até mesmo pois tem esse
aspecto eso é fresca am
criamos aparecer na área fizemos alguns
alguns alguns questionários em inquérito
e vamos entender como é que como
funcionava o negócio do país até ao
momento em vários sítios e percebemos
uma coisa interessante que nós os três
dos três sócios representados no mercado
nós representa 11 um público diferente
flamingo efe então eu e os novos três
dês o que ela está mais próxima de ser a
estudante universitária que saiu da casa
de passagem e e teve que orientar
sozinho né
no dia a dia e portanto o meu contacto
composta por ser da casa de meus pais
foi eu até 21 euros com os lados como
meia você certamente não vivem suas fãs
apesar dos últimos 14 dias a própria
pela minha mãe com quem vivia na casa de
meus pais e tem alguns preconceitos não
tinha por que o site tem algumas
certezas coisas que o
os veículos que não identificava com
elas na coisa de comprar a paz é uma
delas era a questão dos king está
molhado que é eu vou pedir escolheu boys
run
achei ele pega no país alcançou a paz
por dentro do só que ela faz posou só
que em cima dos espanhóis
como é que eu vou agora que o por causa
de pinga escola então como resposta a
isso nós nós temos a coleção do papel
mas depois poderia ter o som só fim mas
elas são de plástico o que imprime
alguns e faz com que seja possível
salvar o país pra provocar comento vapor
trabalho
outra coisa é que o peixe é muito
complicado então e então nós criamos
alguns produtos toda treinando na
posição do país como um produto mais
fácil vender aos seus deputados de pois
neste caso de salmão é que o fato ajudam
a tornar o processo a sessão mais fácil
a pessoa olha o produto entendo o que
fazer com que o caso de roupas o que
acontece quando as pessoas olham uma
garoupa inteira é outra coisa é muito
difícil cozinhar
então nós temos algumas instruções que
têm que tenham situações no verso que
explicam como é que as pessoas usem um
plus eo jean
eu não sou uma grande fã
com isso posso dizer outra coisa hoje em
dia e é em um erro e eu sei que acontece
não foi calculada a mãe
ninguém tem vida para a banca até uma
data de compra após hoje em dia não faz
sentido colocar minha ira ea parceria
para trazer por casa pronta então como
nós também somos um público amplo da
nossa pobre de parceria decidimos abrir
o apetite dias 8 e manha e só aceitei
manhã
o que é interessante porque fomos
percebendo que vamos tendo públicos em
frança a cada hora do dia e vendemos
produtos diferentes por exemplo
alfinetar vendemos muito mais produtos
fáceis cozinhar teve uma posta de salmão
umas pitadas são coisas saem mais
afetado
o kaká é só depois eu puxei ele não
ficar não dá jeito nunca dá jeito passar
não faz mal mas agora fazemos agora
algum tempo fazendo entregas em casa e
eu só vi nem da manhã e fazemos chegar à
faixa casa
bom uma coisa uma das coisas mais
interessantes sobre a sobre vender pois
como todo chá vem é exibida das
cocheiras ea forma de falar que é muito
engraçado é é claro que nós usamos isso
meus amores não como porcaria é claro
nós fazemos isso nós usamos um como como
o tom de voz da nossa marca
temos um grande voz muito muito definido
e sabemos que iremos falar desta forma
com uma peixeira fala uma coisa que não
é assim tão evidente mas nem sempre as
marcas falam como pessoas
ninguém diz leite se enfim aquelas
coisas que só complicam e criam goiânia
está com 15 fome e sabem disso
a eu sei que há muitas coisas que criam
uma saída simples podem servir muito
longe muito longe às vezes as pessoas e
e tentaram chantagear pessoas então
fomos com as pessoas falam isso é uma
coisa quem de sangue faz nos faz sentir
mais próximos e faz com que as pessoas
confiem em nós que é uma coisa que é uma
coisa interessante que acontece quando
as pessoas quando anunciada a confiança
só você não é
então esse foi um erro foi um cartaz que
não sei que nós fazemos nós fazemos
excretados na peixaria comunicado que me
faria isso com seus fãs
eu sempre disse que eu tava complicado
porque minhas férias entretanto
partilhamos num na internet nosso
tamanho só como eu sou mãe pensamos
sentimos está nas redes sociais onde
quer que faça sentido para nós porque
nós é porque nosso público ao tamanho
das redes sociais queremos desmistificar
esta coisa sobre sobre o punch e sobre
este produto que aquele que tem um
entendimento que nem sempre é tão
símbolos ea polícia também temos as
redes sociais então quando nós perdemos
essa foto né
no facebook nem seguro que eu nós
estamos acho foto que até gostava maior
interação eu puxei tem 42 anos e no
santos e nós ressaltamos a fazer as
coisas bem bom
hum até agora falar sobre mim e sobre a
experiência em enfrentar uma parceria
com o pró peixe fresco
obviamente que tem uma loja aberta pra
rua
nós já aprendemos aprendemos muito e
teremos muitos ensaios que eu daquilo
que são os nossos cliente e da
experiência das suas havia uma pessoa
linha e uma coisa que sentimos é que o
primeiro andar sensação no primeiro é
sempre muito improvável quando eu digo
que tenho uma peixaria em provar isso
fazem perguntas e evitamos comitê
organizador já podem ficar muito arranjo
pós e o preenchimento fresco isso enfim
algumas das suas tem algumas
curiosidades que são naturais e além
disso dentro da peixaria sentindo que o
sus tem de ser muito utilizado em enviar
fazer quando está num filme que são duas
pessoas e fluxo assim estava então
arranjado por isso estão muito curiosas
aceitava ver como é que os fãs então nos
com base nisso
nesse ensaio criamos um produto de mais
bom criamos as nossas classes na
parceria que são os shoppings em que nós
ensinamos várias coisas forma
desmistificar essa coisa de consumir paz
1º assentamos quanto ao agente avental e
luvas gorros luvas enfiadas e ensinamos
damos a conhecer às pessoas quais é que
são os sinais do que o peixe fresco isso
nós temos um risco né
as pessoas interagem facto compete nós
temos pessoas com toc toc em abril e ela
aquelas coisas depois damos a explicar
os tipos que pode ser que são mais
apropriados para activos do próprio país
mais magrinhos qualquer coisa pois é os
mais gordinhos servem para determinada
coisa tranquila xisco sair é o próximo
passo que era um país da banca e sua
joão paulo vamos falar das paixões e com
a ajuda do time do filipe joão pois da
forma como quiserem cozinhar mais à
frente porque ela estava com a minha mãe
quando quando nós já tivemos essa idéia
de que as pessoas em uma parceria
enfim a ensinar a arranjar após a minha
mãe fez uma pergunta que fez muito que é
muito pertinente e que eu vou responder
agora a minha mãe perguntou assim entre
as pessoas pagam por isso as pessoas
pagam por isso aprender a aprender a
reagir após que é uma coisa que nós
temos a agradecer aos programas de
engenharia e essa tendência é essa
tendência é ter uma alimentação saudável
e uma vida mais saudável e por isso nós
temos esse produto tem sisu tem 71 20
estantes até quando aproximamos das
pessoas que conseguem gerar conteúdo
tamanho bom o fim deste tempo no entanto
não só com os dois anos depois muita
gente fazer essas perguntas do então os
trabalhos e também tem uma parceria e
quando é que faz a parceria sendo depois
e tu sabes mesmo fazer profissional
enfim
neste momento a mãe do próprio para
pensar e quando às vezes tem que
responder estas coisas respondeu com uma
bola que é sempre a solução mais fácil é
então pra isso porque mesmo tamanho a
pensar no que com as duas coisas são
importantes pra mim aparecendo na área
uma coisa que eu já tinha percebido
antes
com os projetos e conferir se na área
tem certeza absoluta é que trabalhar com
sei que é uma coisa que eu gosto muito
de trabalhar com pessoas das quais gosto
genuinamente é o oitavo em tallin até a
nossa caixa que ele não tenha
apresentado e este é o filipe santos que
eu gosto me antes inco com elas
aprendo muito já tenham muito banho faz
parte do papel delas é assim creche e
ajuda muitas reuniões do irs sócios
quando nós nos damos bem e fazer uma
coisa louca em quando quando está em
quando saiu não goste e só fazer coisas
juntos já que o estilo caiu mais
facilmente sendo mim outra coisa de
santo pra mim também é eu não trabalho
assim há tanto tempo há quatro anos mas
pro causa desde o início tem tem sempre
coisas em para lá com essa torcida fazer
coisas em paralelo que não gosta de
alguma sanção porque são coisas que eu
sinto que eu preciso
são coisas que a gente fica ao lado são
coisas que me alimenta ou fazer melhor
que eu estou fazendo o que eu eo
principal o principal são coisas que me
ajudou em condão e condão nos cursos é
pra fazer melhor a coisa principal
outra coisa que eu tenho sentido tamanha
longo do caminho é que não sei se é que
isso não é coincidência mas as pessoas
que eu conheço que fazem coisas ao lado
e fazem umas coisas tendem a ser mais
interessante que a pessoa tenta fazer
não é bom
a última coisa é a última coisa que eu
queria sentar e metrôs é é um design
trabalho conta com os clientes
com agências muitas vezes o que acontece
é que em creative trabalhar assim sabe
que muitas vezes a coisa sai e nem
sempre eu tô tão confortável com ela
porque às vezes já passou por tanta
coisa que o cliente que o diretor
enfim que o às vezes não é só não acabe
não acredito vítimas jean confortável
sempre que eu tenho feito outra maneira
e eu estivesse na área e serviu para
fazer as coisas que eu acho que devem
ser feitas e e assim noturno um prêmio
investir muito é por isso também serve o
perfil cenário e os guias e imagem
porque acha que ilustrava isso depois
também em torno delas pessoas que
prometem fazer isso é muito
outra coisa que eu pensei ser outra
coisa que eu cheguei a sentar em um
prime de fazer e me deixa muito feliz
é o fim de dar um tempo em que o serviço
vai ficar e de outros motivos político
inclusive uma coisa que me deixa muito
feliz é é terem chamado a voltar pra
falar falar o que eu vou fazer
e seja muito feliz obrigada filhos